[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[грає ритмічна музика]
[Полісся,
село Вербівка]
[кукурікає півень]
Усі потребують любові, і всі її отримують.
Коти, кози та свині — усі разом!
Це Жужа, там Кіся.
[Наталя Вишинська
Співзасновниця екоферми «Вербівка»]
Ця коричнева  — Геллі, як Геллі Бері.
Елвіс, адже в нього зачіска, як у Елвіса Преслі.
Біленька — Монро, Мерлін Монро.
Наших свиней ми кличемо іменами моделей:
Наомі Кемпбелл, Тайра Бенкс,
Лінда Євангеліста
і ще Саманта — маленька дівчинка.
Далі лише хлопці.
Усі вони дуже компанійські.
Свині люблять куштувати одяг.
Ми їх постійно гладимо,
ми з ними постійно граємось.
Монро! Вона любить шнурки.
Я зробила ароматну грядку.
Ми намагаємося використовувати
кілька разів речі,
які дехто викидає.
Наприклад, бабусине взуття
я використала як прикрасу для клумби.
Посадила квіточки,
і влітку у нас буде квітуче взуття.
Йдемо далі, я покажу,
як ми садимо картоплю.
Я не копала.
У мене була земля така —
суцільна трава, як-от поряд.
Я лише поклала на землю сіно,
розклала картоплю
й покрила ще одним шаром сіна.
Коли вона проросте, я ще додам сіно.
Усе!
Це тирса, чи картон, чи трава, чи сіно.
Воно присипає землю.
На такому городі не росте бур'ян,
там розвивається своя органіка.
Черви рихлять землю,
і її не треба перекопувати, земля рихла,
вона зберігає вологу,
землю не потрібно поливати,
не потрібно копати.
Земля здоровіша й не потребує удобрення.
Адже сама система з червами
виробляє удобрення.
Схожі традиції давно існують.
Щоправда, коли був Радянський союз
після колективізації ці всі знання стали другорядними.
Старше покоління
досі використовує ці традиції.
Як присипати сіном,
обробити землю.
Покоління наших батьків звикло копати,
полоти,
аж поки вистачить сили.
Якщо живий дійдеш додому — це вже добре.
Ми, навпаки, хочемо,
щоб це все відбувалось гармонійно і в радість.
Щоб вирощування рослин
і догляд за тваринами не були тяжкими.
Просто захотілося жити на природі.
Тому що в Києві з цим дуже важко.
Постійно хворіла, стреси, депресії,
робота в офісі.
Це мене не влаштовувало.
Тут земля й будинок.
Нам захотілося — ми зібрали фактично за день
всі наші речі і переїхали.
Дуже хочеться побудувати біовегетарій,
щоб вирощувати овочі
та навчати дітей,
як правильно вирощувати
органічні овочі протягом року.
Тому що теплиці — це лише один сезон,
а в біовегетарії
можна вирощувати і взимку.
Я маю на увазі екологічні продукти.
[У планах] завести вермиферму,
організувати сортування сміття
— це наші проєкти, які ми хочемо реалізувати
в межах екологічного навчання для школи.
Тут жили пращури Євгена.
Дідусі, бабусі, прадідусі...
Я працював у бізнесі, був громадським діячем
і на державній службі.
[Євген Вишинський
Співзасновник екоферми «Вербівка»]
Багато всього було.
Я відчував, що це не моє:
не розвивався духовно й морально.
Зараз я почуваюся краще
й дійсно займаюся тим, чим хочу.
Я маю достатньо часу для розвитку та творчості,
для того, щоб просто сісти і подивитися на небо.
На природі є більше можливостей,
щоб розібратися в собі.
Нікуди не поспішаєш,
тебе не відволікає інформаційний шум,
який не несе нічого позитивного
і жодної інформації.
Тут можна більше відчути себе,
розвиватися морально й фізично,
щось робити руками.
Це настільки дає внутрішній
сильний монолітний стан.
Це мені дуже подобається!
Ми не хочемо все здоров'я вкладати в землю,
як це робили наші батьки.
А спокійно [працювати] в гармонії з природою,
щоб це було в задоволення.
На мою думку, українці можуть усе,
тільки іноді їм чогось бракує...
Головне— любити свою землю,
адже з цієї любові йде все.
Тоді збережеться природа, земля
та взаємини між людьми й між собою.
Коли є любов до своєї землі,
тоді є любов до всього.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Михайло Тітов]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Заукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Наталя Кірякова]
[Музика
Panivalkova]
[Субтитри
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Екпедиція]